[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you have gone up a level to level two, and what that means is that you have to pick two spells that you can add into your spell book, but you have to find research material to be able to do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And, um, uh, also
[SPEAKER_01]: You are a transmuter.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've picked being a transmuter, so you want to be able to pick spells that are transmutation spells, because those are the ones that are most interesting.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ryan, do you remember when you were coming up with my character, do you remember any of the stuff I was planning on adding in my future levels?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Inventor was one of the things you wanted to be able to do.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alchemist was another thing that you wanted to be able to do because you wanted to bring the industrial revolution to this fantasy world.
[SPEAKER_01]: How do I get to do that?
[SPEAKER_01]: You got a fourth level and you get a feat.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're just two levels away from being able to get a feat either inventor or alchemist.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I think the thing to do now is to come up with ideas.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of what you want to create and what you want to make.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there a thing I can get from unlocking that can just give me the brain power for ideas, like you were just saying?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, if you get alchemist, you're somebody that's going to be able to work very well with compounds and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you get an inventor, you can actually start making contraptions and designing them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: What would you recommend?
[SPEAKER_01]: Alchemist or...?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it depends on where you want to go.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I think really for you, the story should guide you into what you become interested in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: When I get to level four, I get one fee.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then how do I get... What does it take to get a second one?
[SPEAKER_00]: Go to level eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you get Inventor and Alchemist together, that's a powerful combination.
[SPEAKER_00]: So alchemist gets to create a lot of ideas on your own, is what you're saying?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, what an inventor does is they make contraptions.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Inventor can make like, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like locks or traps or devices that do certain things.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alchemists make like chemicals and magical powders and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think I'd want inventors.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if you put them together...
[SPEAKER_01]: And you can make gunpowder that goes into a pistol.
[SPEAKER_01]: The inventor makes the pistol and the alchemist makes the gunpowder.
[SPEAKER_00]: If I did do alchemist, I feel like I'd want to have at least... How much gold do you think it'd take to hire inventors?
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, that might not be a bad idea.
[SPEAKER_01]: It would probably take some money.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was gonna say, because I could, like, is there like a main city that the whole, like, place revolves around that we go to every now and then?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you know that Greyhawk City is a great city.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gratzel is a great city.
[SPEAKER_01]: Iola Drah is a great city.
[SPEAKER_01]: Monmurg is actually a great city where there are a lot of people that come.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and I could.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to try to start a factory or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: Start a brand.
[SPEAKER_00]: Totally.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I think the guy you work for...
[SPEAKER_01]: He has his own brand, he had his own shop, and you were probably trying to work on projects that he wanted.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did I get any gold as a starter thing from him?
[SPEAKER_00]: Ten gold coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: What?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten gold coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: But here's the deal.
[SPEAKER_01]: In his shop, you know that there was a lot of knowledge and a lot of stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually, you're kind of interested in seeing... Can I get a pencil then?
[SPEAKER_01]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh oh, something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I continue what you're saying?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're actually interested in seeing what he's got, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, let's go ahead and start.